here's the thing with bitcoin versus  fiat fiat you can confiscate first thing  with bitcoin  you have to go through the process of  trying to confiscate funds before you  actually take possession of them and  that asymmetry it gives you the high  ground as a defender and it actually  makes the law have to work first before  action is taken when you had gofundme  they were able to just freeze it with a  phone call or a button click or whatever  but with bitcoin they can't do that so  they have to literally file an  injunction they have to use police  officers they have to go to people's  homes  it makes the government do the work to  go like docs or arrest people which is  really important  [Music]